[Music]
by divine wisdom gosh quiet shut they
have our scent run
just keep running
are you out of your mind he's not going
to make it he has to bless the decorator
protects me but I define taste
look at me all the gold we want is right
there
oh I just came knowledge
no breach the seal get us through that
door
Oh help me
by three it says the blood of the
Willing come on you gotta be kidding me
that worked
we have to open he's a doll
as Jamie didn't make it
oh well chewed up gold supplies about
three weeks instead of four must be
hidden here somewhere
read this
but by three they come by 3/3 way open
despite a lot of them willing hail hail
the Creator huh it hails the daughter no
no no no what about the coin was it say
this is forbidden this is a summoning I
cannot speak don't lie to me we came
here
thanks pleasure what is this place I
don't know maybe maybe city or two
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we call
takes me open your eyes
that protects me it sort of like
protects me it's all there is no light
here you came to the darkness for
knowledge
and all the knowledge you seek is here
surrender speak the words call her home
by 3:00 they come by 3:00 thy way opens
by the blood of the Willing we call thee
home
[Music]
daughter of
create of sanctuary
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Blessed Mother
save us
[Music]
you